hear the community Gathers
grieving parents families and Neighbors
funeral rites and prayers take place as
they remember the 36 lives taken among
them is am the only child to survive the
massacre totally unscathed
her mother says her three-year-old homie
survived because the gunman thought she
was already dead
an official said when they went in and
was still asleep
when she was found she woke up but she
was sleeping facing the wall she didn't
see her friends who were lying there so
she carried her out and covered her head
with a blanket so she couldn't see
anything
the family are grieving
panoply lost her cousin in the attack he
was killed outside the daycare
in the days that have followed the
center has become a makeshift Memorial
hundreds gather to pay their respects a
trauma team is on the ground for people
who need the support
if we can provide an adequate
psychological first aid and stabilize
the community as early as possible they
can the the event will left the smallest
impact to the Next Generation but if we
do nothing
okay I agree with you that if you do
nothing the psychological wound or
psychological trauma will embed it in
this generation
no generation has seen an attack like
this before it's the country's deadliest
mass shooting
the 34 year old attacker was panya
kamrab a former police officer fired
from his job in June for drug use his
final Act was murdering his wife and son
before taking his own life
police say kamrab carried out the attack
because of constant stress around family
money and his legal case
this is a community in warning
remembering the innocent lives lost the
young lives ended just as they've begun
Aisha zahid Sky News